all the women that are on only fans if
they had a strong dad that said no you
are not doing that in a million years I
think that would be a good thing and I
think sometimes we need to be told no
yes agreed and growing up my dad was
very hard to make being like Sophia but
what are you doing don't do that yeah
and obviously having three brothers as
well I saw things that they were doing
and I was like I don't want to be like
that yeah I need to change the past that
day's gone what would they do oh just
that fashion side okay but
um I saw the way they were going with
their life and I was like I'm going down
the street but I've also been very
strong man since a young age always
known what I've wanted to do like I was
watching uh well it's a white place when
I was like five oh no way and I saw
Selena Gomez and I like that's gonna be
me oh on TV and now I'm in the
background yet to be main character you
just wait okay